well I don't know that we fall for them
we accept them let's not put it quite
that way people like fantasy they they
like to believe that there is a
supernatural world out there and devils
and angels and all kinds of things like
that they like to believe in that kind
of mythology and if they can be part of
it if they can be part of the action or
witness something to that effect they
like to do it a legitimate magician as
myself a conjurer that is will always
tell his audience that what you're
saying is simple tricks they're
illusions they don't really happen or at
least you try to get that idea across to
them after all I think very few people
think that David Copperfield actually
uses a buzz saw to cut a girl in two
pieces because that would be a waste of
beautiful girls for one thing and the
costumes will be all torn up and
everything to be an awful waste so it's
actually a trick it's an illusion these
are very good illusions in most cases or
they don't work at all so you've either
got to be good at the thing or you're
not in the business any longer but
people do enjoy seeing this kind of
fantasy happen how much in the days of
computerized movies now where it can
perform miracles on the screen on the on
the silver screen as they say and in 3d
remember that the magician is is sort of
challenged to do something just just a
bit bigger than what he or she did the
last time and it's getting more and more
challenging for the the conjuring
profession but you've got Penn and
Teller you got last burden you've got
black king you got people in in Las
Vegas like that is Terry on every day
not my King has been doing the same act
for like 16 or 18 years now and why
because he's pretty damn good at it
highly entertaining he doesn't have to
be a mystical character he's a magician
and he's funny and he's entertaining
he's quick I got great wit and such as
Penn and Teller and Lansford and do of
course but they're pros they're
dyed-in-the-wool froze and they are
great examples of the country yard on
the other hand we have the so-called
psychics out there who say they can bend
spoon
that their minds da it on do ESP and
various things like that and these are
people who are lying to the public
they're they're not playing fair with
them at all and they're leading them
astray and they're taking away in my
observation their emotional security as
well as their money